EKE
EK
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE HAVE EXCLUSIVE NEW
INFORMATION TONIGHT ABOUT ONE OF
THE MOST PERPLEXING MYSTERIES IN
WASHINGTON.
TODAY HE IS LEAVING HIS JOB.
THE MOST OBVIOUS QUESTION IS
WHY?
WAS HE PUSHED OR DID HE DECIDE
TO LEAVE HIMSELF.
McCABE'S NAME HAS BEEN IN THE
NEWS FOR YEARS.
IN 2016 HIS WIFE TOOK A LARGE
SUM OF MONEY COLLECTED BY ONE OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S CLOSEST
FRIEND.
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER WHERE SHE
WAS EXONERATED BEFORE SHE WAS
EVEN INTERVIEWED.
McCABE NEVER RECUSED HIMSELF
FROM THAT INVESTIGATION.
WAS ANDREW McCABE FIRED?
WAS THAT FIRING A RESULT OF
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
STILL FAMOUS BUT STILL
MYSTERIOUS HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
MEMO?
THE ONE NOBODY OUTSIDE OF
CONGRESS HAS READ?
WE DECIDED TO SPEND THE DAY
FINDING OUT ALL WE COULD ABOUT
THAT MEMO.
WE MADE A LOT OF CALLS AND
TALKED TO PEOPLE WHO READ IT.
HERE'S WHAT WE LEARNED.
THE MEMO WHICH IS 4 PAGES LONG
DESCRIBES ABUSES OF FISA WHICH
PURPOSE OF STOPPING FOREIGN
HAPPEN IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES AND NEVER FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAD FISA TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
THAT LAW WAS ABUSED.
THE MEMO DESCRIBES HOW.
QUOTE:
"SHOCKING" SAID ONE PERSON WHO
READ IT.
ANDREW McCABE IS MENTIONED IN
CONFIRMED.
THAT IS THE REASON HE LEFT THE
JOB TODAY?
WE COULD NOT GET A DEFINITIVE
ANSWER.
IN THE COURSE OF OUR REPORTING
WE LEARNED SOMETHING ELSE.
McCABE IS THE SUBJECT OF ONE
INTERNAL DOJ INVESTIGATION AND
INVESTIGATING POLITICAL'S
MOTIVATED BEHAVIOR AT THE BUREAU
TIED TO HOROWITZ'S WORK.
AMONG THE SUBJECTS OF FISA
WARRANTS IS A PERSON AFFILIATED
HAVE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
PAGE WAS AN ACTIVE AGENT OF A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT AND A SPY
FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT CLAIM LOOKS ABSURD.
PAGE WAS NEVER INDICTED FOR
SPYING ON ANYBODY.
IF PAGE IS A RUSSIAN AGENT, WHY
IS HE NOT IN HAND CUFFS?
ON THE BASIS OF THAT NUTTY
CLAIM, THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DID SURVEILLANCE ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE MEMO SHOWS THAT WHEN THE DOJ
WANTED TO SPY ON CARTER PAGE
THEY USED INFORMATION FROM THE
DISCREDITED STEELE DOSSIER FOR
THEIR BASIS.
ONE PERSON SAID THE FBI HAS BEEN
POLITICIZED FOR YEARS.
NOW IT'S BEING EXPOSED FOR
EFFORTS TO UNDERMINE A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE.
NEITHER HAS ALMOST ANYBODY
ALLEGATIONS.
THEY ARE MORE TROUBLING THAN THE
UNDERLYING CRIME IN WATERGATE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A TRUMP
VOTER TO UNDERSTAND THE
POLITICAL USE OF INTELLIGENCE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CAN
DESTROY A COUNTRY FASTER THAN
ANYTHING ELSE CAN.
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE.
HOW DO WE KNOW?
WE CHECKED.
COMMITTEE READ THAT MEMO.
READ IT.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, AMAZING IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, ONLY A FEW
DEMOCRATS HAVE BOTHERED TO READ
THE MEMO THEY ARE ALL TO A
PERSON AGAINST RELEASING IT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THEY
WANT.
WE HOPE WE CAN MAKE OUR OWN
JUDGMENTS TO DECIDE WHAT IS IN
THAT MEMO.
DAN IS A FORMER SECRET SERVICE
AGENT AND NYPD OFFICER.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
POLITICIZED.
>> WHERE ARE THE DEMOCRATS?
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE PARTY OF
CIVIL LIBERTIES.
THE CONSITUTIONAL REPUBLIC CAN'T
EXIST IF THE 4TH AMENDMENT IS
SUBJECT TO THE R OR D IN NOT
FRO -- IN FRONT OF YOUR NAME.
TO SPY ON SOMEONE IN THE UNITED
STATES IN LEGAL IF YOU PRODUCE
NONE OF THAT HAS BEEN PRODUCED.
NOT A SINGLE DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN HAS PRODUCED ANY
EVIDENCE THAT ANYONE ON THE
TRUMP TEAM COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS TO JUSTIFY AN
UNITED STATES FROM THE OPPOSING
PARTY.
THIS IS DEVASTATING.
>> Tucker: WHAT COULD BE THE
RATIONALE FOR NOT READING THE
MEMO?
HOW CAN THEY EXPLAIN THAT?
>> THE WAY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
WORKS, THE SYSTEMS ARE NOT
INTER-CONNECTED.
THE CLOUD OR THE INTERNET.
IT'S IN TUCKER'S PLACE, RIGHT?
TO READ IT YOU HAVE TO GO TO
TUCKER'S PLACE.
IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE THAT
NUNES WENT BACK IN MARCH TO THE
IS VERY LIKELY WILL BE IN THIS
MEMO?
WHAT AM I SAYING?
THE INFORMATION WAS BRIEFED TO
HILLARY CLINTON AND ALL OF THE
STUFF IN THE DOSSIER AND ALL OF
OBAMA.
WHY ELSE WOULD NUNES HAVE TO GO
TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO READ IT?
>> Tucker: THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
IS IT PLAUSIBLE THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS REALLY
BELIEVED THAT POOR CARTER PAGE
FOR THE RIGHT TO SPY ON HIM?
>> I BELIEVE YOU CAN CONVINCE